[Music]
when you're on a trail that long you
don't really think about how long is it
going to take me to get to somewhere or
how fast am i going you're thinking
about don't get yourself hurt
my name is karl meltzer and i am an
ultra marathoner
we did 36 miles yeah it was pretty weak
day but no one's ever been this far in
10 days
i just recently broke the appalachian
trail record from maine to georgia it's
uh 2189 miles and i completed that in 45
days
22 hours and 38 minutes beating the
previous record by
just a little under 10 hours total
mileage average per day for that 46 days
would be 47.6
the at is not a walk in the park it's a
hard trail every time i cook my foot and
it goes forward it totally stresses
really quick
i scream in pain you really have to have
a team it's not just the one guy running
there's a couple peanut butter jelly
it's really the crew who
if they're not perfect for you then it
really won't be successful
i think the appalachian trail not only
is it very popular and iconic but it's
also very difficult now it's all
downhill and easy i am concentrating on
my foot placement all the time so two
hours goes by like nothing just because
i'm zoned i'm zoned out
i slammed my head into the ground a
number of times and to beat you down you
have to expect that but you can beat it
too as long as you just keep persevering
and fighting through the issues that
you're going to have
[Music]
the last day i ran 85 miles my body was
so amped and ready to be done that
it didn't matter really how far it was i
felt the same in mile 80 as i did at
mile 10 my you're just numb at that
point really this is where all the fun
is it's important for people to know
that the ap is a special place and it
should be protected
it's a trail for one who wants to gain
fellowship with nature no matter whether
you're running it whether you're walking
it whether you're taking 10 years to do
it when you walk that trail you have a
vibe and you feel it
every year someone else's gets a little
bit faster
someone will break my record for sure it
might come this year i don't know i'm
still gonna be happy because i gave it
everything i had you know i think that's
what's important
[Music]
you